las desigualdades estructurales en
América Latina y el Caribe las raíces
del incremento del trabajo infantil en
la región unos 8,8 millones de menores
de edad realizan trabajos y más de 5,5
millones son particularmente peligrosos
según alertó la organización
Internacional del trabajo en el Día
Mundial por la erradicación del trabajo
infantil el trabajo infantil es la cara
visible de dificultades estructurales
que tienen los propios países la mayoría
de los niños y niñas que trabajan tienen
que abandonar la escuela esto supone no
solamente que estos chicos y chicas
estén haciendo o llevando a cabo una
actividad laboral sino además que se
interrumpa esa trayectoria que le va Le
va a permitir crecer a lo largo de la
vida y ir mejorando en esos puestos de
trabajo y en ese tipo de trabajo y
afectan a su salud
pensemos que los niños y las niñas están
expuestos a situaciones riesgosas de
trabajos peligrosos una mancha que se
expande desde Argentina hasta México
cuyas cifras aumentaron la pandemia de
Kobe 19 el empobrecimiento de las
economías latinoamericanas y el aumento
de trabajos informales esta vulneración
a los derechos de los niños y niñas
afecta directamente a su educación
desarrollo y salud siendo los menores de
área Rurales entre ellos los indígenas
los que engrosan las cifras México es de
segundo país con mayor prevalencia de
trabajo infantil según la cepal una
situación que también preocupa en
Centroamérica en Guatemala casi un
millón de menores trabajan el 60% en
zonas Rurales y pesados esfuerzos por su
erradicación en Brasil en 2019 había más
de 2 millones de niños y adolescentes
trabajando la región Ha logrado
importantes avances redoblemos los
esfuerzos para que la erradicación del
trabajo infantil en la región sea una
realidad de continuar al ritmo actual se
estima que serían necesarios más de 25
años para erradicar por completo esta
problemática La abolición del trabajo
infantil es un Pilar para lograr la
justicia social en todo el mundo según
reivindical los organismos humanitarios